You know, this is funny,
'cause you come on this show.
You've been here several times.
You're always, you know you're
a lot of fun to talk to.
And then I get this,
there's this image of Harrison Ford
that's out there, that you're grumpy.
There's this, grumpy Harrison Ford image.
That's horse (beep)
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
Okay
(audience cheering)
Maybe first thing in
the morning, you know.
Right right, occasionally.
Before my coffee.
Before your coffee.
But I'm not a grumpy person.
[Conan] No no, I don't think so at all.
I don't think so at all.
Well good.
(Conan laughing)
(audience laughing)
Man, you give a look.
We've talked about this before,
but you can give a look.
Can we just, just give me that look again.
You can give a look that just-
Look at that!
(audience clapping)
I don't have that.
I would kill to have an
intimidating look like that.
I have this kind of thing.
(audience laughing)
And it doesn't, it means nothing.
It does nothing. People giggle.
Yeah.
Little girls giggle when I
try and intimidate people.
Well, don't do that.
[Conan] Okay, I won't. I'll stop doing it.
Do that.
Let me ask you a little
bit about your life now.
You're you're living here in New York.
No.
Okay.
(audience laughing)
My research is flawed.
No, I'm living in Los Angeles.
My kids are in school in Los Angeles.
So I spend the school year there.
You spend a school year there.
You do have a place that
you moved into downtown.
Is that true?
Well, near downtown.
[Conan] Near downtown, we
don't want to get too specific.
Well, near New York. It's, yeah.
Okay. Yeah.
Well, when you invite me over
I'll know the specific address
Right.
(audience laughs)
You can give that to me at any time.
It doesn't have to be now.
Yeah. Yeah.
But it was in the paper
recently that you were,
let's say living somewhere
in this general area
walking around and you
hadn't installed blinds
and neighbors were watching you
and it was reported that you
were walking around naked
and I just have to ask about it.
'Cause that's my job. Gotta ask about it.
(audience laughing)
No, it's not true.
[Conan] Not true. No truth to that at all.
No.
[Conan] Okay.
That's not true.
[Conan] Yeah. Not true.
I...
It's not true.
[Conan] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
It's not true, I would
never do anything like that.
Never do anything like that.
I'm a very sort of
reserved and shy person.
[Conan] Right right.
So you were fully closed at
all times, walking around.
Yeah. Well not fully closed, but clothed.
Mostly closed.
Mostly clothed
From here up.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
[Conan] Okay I'm picturing it now.
Yeah. This is going,
there's a direction we've taken tonight.
I'm not sure I'm that comfortable with it.
It all began with penis mullet.
(audience laughing)
I'm very ashamed of what I do.
(audience laughs)
Let me ask you something.
And this is a question I've
wanted to ask you for a while
and I've always restrained myself.
Yeah
Star Wars of course came
out in 1977 I believe.
Huge international hit, one of
the biggest hits of all time.
Rockets you to superstardom.
And then shortly afterwards
a Christmas special came out
that was produced by George Lucas
and which all of the
participants in Star Wars were,
(audience laughing)
came together and they made this
Star Wars Christmas special.
And the tape's been
passed around for years.
And the rumors is that Lucas
is trying to suppress it
'cause none of you look happy
while you're making this thing.
(audience laughing)
And I thought I'd just ask you about it.
Do you remember making
this Christmas special?
I think it was 1978.
No, you don't remember it?
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
You have no memory of this incident.
No, none whatsoever.
[Conan] No memory of it at all.
No.
So it doesn't exist in your-
No it doesn't exist.
It doesn't exist?
No
What if I were to tell
you that I had a little
piece of tape right now?
(audience cheering)
No!
What if I were to roll that piece of tape?
How would you feel about that?
(audience cheering)
I wouldn't feel.
(audience laughing)
I don't know. I've never seen it.
Maybe it'll be nice.
(audience laughing)
Go ahead, roll it.
(Star Wars theme music)
[Announcer] The Star Wars Holiday Special.
Chewie, check and see if
the coast is clear, will ya?
(wookiee language)
You're like family to me.
(audience laughing)
(wookiee language)
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
(audience laughing)
That wookiee looked at you
with, with lust. That was-
Real affection.
[Conan] (laughs) Quasi affection. Yeah.
[Harrison] Yeah.